(percussion et chant)
- Un chant traditionnel
pour un moment significatif.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
premier ministre du Canada
investir jusqu'à 800 millions
de dollars dans quatre grands
projets de conservation dirigés
par les peuples autochtones
d'un bout à l'autre du pays,
qui représentent un total
de près d'un million
de kilomètres carrés.
- Des projets de conservation
pilotés par des peuples
longtemps, une étape importante
vers la réconciliation.
"Pour que des peuples
puissent réaliser leur vision
de la conservation et de la
protection de la biodiversité",
Une annonce qui arrive
à e e e en ce premier jour
de la COP15. Un message envoyé
aux négociateurs alors
de cette rencontre est s s s s'r
30 % des terres et des mers
d'ici 2030 et d'incluresssssssss
dans le processus.
- Nous allons continuer
de faire le travail de façon
agressive parce qu'on setetetetr
les futures générations futures
et on se doit de démontrer
aussi l'exemple aux autres
pays du monde.e e e e e e e e e,
ici, aux messages lancés par
des Autochtones de partout
sur la planète.ncncncncncncncnc,
d'Antigua-et-Barbuda,
y voit dans ces collaborations
la clé de la préservation
Pour faire place à ces projets
collaboratifs de conservation,
il faudra freinerininininininins
et celles des banques.
ANTONIO GUTERRES, secrétaire
général des Nations unies
- Et ce que nos s s s s s s s ss
les institutions financières,
c'est de présenter des plans,
des plans qui puissent être
vérifiésacacacacacacacacacacacas
renouvelables.
- Un message entre autres
dirigé aux grandes banques
du Canada qui ont augmenté leurs
investissements dans l'industrie
des énergies fossiles en 2021.
aurait même doublé son aide
à l'industrie.
Ici Elisa Serret,
Radio-Canada, Montréa